there's a march now we're getting up to
the bridge what's got to be concerned is
there's some big breakers and you need
speed to time it to get out between the
breaks and that's the one thing we don't
have on this boat is speed we're gonna
have to make a judgment call once we get
out there and look coming across the bar
black and grill yeah he's letting her
eat
I wouldn't do it I'm through there
I'm gonna take that under advisement
crap
job written thank you Jesus we're
through there
so long
I could hurt you
really got some speed we got a big hot
bow so it's not that much of an issue
for us I would not want to be on the
hard merch trying this today
all right let's take a look coming up on
the bar here at bars big there's some
rollers coming up there Wow look at it
hot water one thing going on throughout
of water in the end who didn't let me
take a big way then you know what we
snapped it through all right off now if
you ever done filler of water
snap I've will pump right off to inch
through all coming into those what
happened
Tyler's filling up with water what's
going to happen today is we ain't going
out here's what we risk happening is if
we hit get hit by one of those breaking
waves it's going to punch the bright
windows out or worse these other guys
are making it and they're making it just
barely and they got boats then if twice
if not three times faster than mine but
it just ain't worth the risk today